[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I just might to million more
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
yeah
can we do tests where we yeah anyway
yeah - leave our game
why'd you dump in a good way
it'll be tight low sometime right it's
like yeah we are looking to wash off
free shot like that you can't be kinda
neat see the flags a bit rough yeah you
go to close and start getting weird
oh no I gotta save it one other one one
we call work what we meant to do but you
get me there is that when you wide or if
you wanna go wide and you're worried
okay yeah screams okay think we're
allowed can shoot your bit sites screens
I hope you over there
[Music]
we're not we're not ready
I'll keep you then I'll take it out
good everybody positions TV
[Music]
why'd you back to the present
I'm starving
- I like it
coming
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the lights like a chain you'll see
baby
you start I start as usually went that
we won't state we made about
I'll continue my image interaction yeah
what would their white hat
I saw burning wood last night and I saw
my god yeah I saw something
- we've got the stomach invited
life combined 89 260 I'm looking going
to actually younger than me early
amazing did you see
of the the ocean
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon everybody and thank you
very much for coming
I just chaired a meeting of the
government's Emergency Committee
including ministers from Scotland Wales
and normally that's coronavirus COBE 19
continues and will continue to spread
across the world and our country over
the next few months we've done what can
be done to contain this disease and this
is for last valuable time but it's now a
global pandemic and the number of cases
will rise Charlie be the T number of
cases is higher perhaps much higher than
the number of cases we have so far
confirmed with tests and IB clearly what
we did this is the worst public health
crisis for a generation some people
compare it to seasonal flu right owing
to the lack of immunity this disease is
more dangerous and it's going to do you
live with the British public more
families and many more families are
going to lose loved ones before their
time and chief scientific adviser we've
set out the best information we have on
that in a moment
but as we've said at the last few weeks
we have a clear plan but we are now
working through and we're now getting on
to the next phase in that plan because
this is now not just an attempt to
contain the disease as far as possible
but to delay its spread and thereby
minimize the suffering if we delay the
peak even by a few weeks then our NHS
will be in a stronger state as the
weather improves and fewer people suffer
from normal respiratory diseases more
heads are avenged
and you'll have more time for medical
research we can also have to stretch the
peak of the disease over a longer period
so that our society is better able to
cope the chief medical officer will set
out our lines of defense we have to
deploy these at the right time to
maximize their effect the most important
task will be to protect our elderly and
most vulnerable people during the peak
weeks when there is the maximum risk of
exposure to the disease and when the NHS
will be under the most pressure so the
most dangerous period is not now but
some weeks away depending on how fast it
spreads today therefore we're moving
forward with our plan from tomorrow if
you have coronavirus symptoms however
while either a new continuous cough or a
high temperature then you should stay at
home for at least seven days to protect
others and help slow the spread of the
disease we advise all those over seventy
with serious medical conditions against
going on cruises and we advise against
international school trips at some point
in the next few weeks we are likely to
go further and if someone in our
household has those symptoms we will be
asking everyone in that household to
stay at home we're not introducing this
measure yet for reasons Sir Patrick will
explain but I want to signal now that
this is coming down the track we are
considering the question of banning
major public events such as sporting
fixtures and the scientific advices
we've said over the last couple of weeks
is that this banning such events will
have little effect on the spread but
there is also the issue of the bird
that such events can place on public
services so we're discussing these
issues with colleagues in all parts of
the United Kingdom and we'll have more
to say shortly about the timing of
further action in that respect at all
stages we have been guided by the
science and we will do the right thing
at the right time we are not repeat not
closing schools now the scientific
advice is that this could do more harm
than good at this time but of course
we're keeping this under review and this
again may change as the disease spreads
schools should only close if they're
specifically advised to do so that
remains are applies there is no escaping
the reality that these measures will
cause severe disruption across our
country for many months the best
scientific advice is that this will help
us slow the disease and save lives
there will be detailed information
available on the NHS website and from
one one one online stress something
that's very important in the wake of
what we're saying this afternoon I urge
people who think in view of what we're
saying about their potential symptoms
that they should stay at home I urge
them not to call one one one but to use
the internet for information if they can
I also want at this stage there to speak
directly to older people because this
disease is particularly dangerous for
you for all the people even though the
vast majority of older people will
experience a mild to moderate illness I
know that many people will be very
worried
and I think we should all be thinking
about our elderly relatives the more
vulnerable members of our family our
neighbors and everything we can do to
protect them over the next few months
we're going to need to mobilize millions
of people to help and support each other
and I just watch you can learn the
government will do all we can to help
you and your family during this period
we're not just going to be as you saw
yesterday supporting the economy during
this period we will be providing money
and many other forms of support and
helping communities to support each
other and as we've done over the last
few weeks we will continue to provide as
soon as we have it as much clearer
scientific and medical information as we
can so I'd like to end by repeating that
two more messages with which you all
have become familiar it is still right
that's more vital than ever that we
remember to wash our hands and lastly of
course even if things seem tough now
just remember that we will get through
this this country will get through this
epidemic just as it has got through many
tougher experiences before if we look
out for each other and commit
wholeheartedly to a full national effort
and I'd like to thank my class the
Baptist balance our chief I like to
thank these big I like to thank mr.
Patrick R sub a pea plants our chief
scientific adviser to set out the latest
facts and the state of play as he sees
so this is a new disease and novice has
to it as time is reset and that's a key
part of what we're looking at here it is
entering a new phase the w-h-o has
called this a global pandemic and we're
entering a delay phase it's important to
recognize that the contained phase of
case identification and isolation has
had an effect to delay things up until
now and currently we're on a trajectory
that looks as though it's about four
weeks or so behind Italy and other some
other countries in Europe that means
that we've now reached a stage when the
epidemic I just want to show you on on
earth on a slide will appear this is the
shape of an epidemic so you go on the
awesome for some time with not very much
happening and that's probably where we
are now
there are currently 590 cases that have
been identified in the UK and there are
more than 20 patients on intensive care
units if you calculate what that really
means in terms of the total number it's
much more likely that we've got
somewhere between five and ten thousand
people infected at the moment we've
identified 590 the same sorts of ratios
will be true in other countries
depending on how much testing they've
done that's still a relatively small
number we're still on the flat part as
these curves start to take off as more
people get it they take off quite
steeply and that's why timing is so
important because what you want to do is
to protect people during the most
infectious period and I explained that
in just a minute
so we're in a period now where we've got
some but it hasn't yet taken off the
actions that we need to take are to try
to do two things it's to delay this will
come on
it is to delay the peep and to push the
peak down so we're trying to reduce the
number of cases at any one time
that's very important for NHS in order
to make the NHS able to cope with this
and it's also important because it
pushes it out into summer months where
the NHS is less busy but also where
there may be less
transmission of virus respiratory
infections in general tend to be a bit
less common so that's why name is to
change the shape of this and it's
important to recognize it's not to stop
everybody gets me you can't do that it's
not possible to stop everybody getting
it and it's also actually not desirable
because you want some amusing in the
population we need to have immunity to
protect ourselves from this in the
future
the second big aim that we need to look
for is how in that we protect the
vulnerable and the elderly who are at
most risk of serious illness and dying
from this and the way this disease looks
as though it appears is that you have
five days or so of my viral illness and
then a small proportion of people get a
second phase where they have some sort
of immune response to it which causes
the damage and the elderly and the sick
are much more likely to get that so
during the period of peak transmission
we need to protect them at that phase
and if you look at the curves it becomes
obvious if you do that at the moment
you're not protecting anybody really
because then the number of cases are too
small if you do it the right time then
you're protecting them over the peak and
you're not asking them to be in
isolation for too long
similarly with the idea of households
going into complete isolation that comes
a bit later when you've got some more
cases coming up at the moment if you
asked households to complete the isolate
at one person's ill most people could
not pack coronavirus you may have to do
the whole thing all over again and what
happens then is the effect of that wanes
because people get fed up with doing
this and you end up with not being able
to do it time and time again so the
timing is critical and that's true
across all of the interventions we've
looked at that's why this is the package
things that need to happen at the right
time and in the right pacing in terms of
mass gatherings and schools schools it's
true that there's some effect in closing
schools but that effect is minimal and
actually you'd have to do it for 13 to
16 weeks or longer and you don't need to
be a very advanced mathematician to work
out that the chances of keeping children
not speaking to each other or playing
with each other at the 30 to 16 weeks is
zero and therefore we have to be very
careful to make sure you take the right
measures that will stop this rather than
things which might end up with children
for example going to stay with
grandparents at a time when they might
be most vulnerable so the idea is to do
things at the right time not to end up
with measures stopping during the peak
in exposing more people to illness and
I'll hand over to chief medical officer
to explain in more detail the measures
that are being proposed
so I'll just amplify just a few of the
points that have just been made first of
all we are clearly now stopping the
contained phase of this operation that
we've always said from beginning there
were four stages to this contain delay
research and mitigate and contain
finishes from today
fantastic work has been done by my
colleagues in the NHS and in public
health across all four nations
and as a result of that finding the
early cases they were imported isolating
them with the consent of the people
involved which we are very grateful and
following the chains of transmission
that has helped to slow down the sealing
of this virus and has pushed it out in
time so the delay has already begun as a
result of the work of our colleagues and
the public spiritedness of people who
came forward for testing but now we move
on to the next phase and I think that's
made very clear by the fact that the
World Health Organization yesterday
declared this as a global pandemic and
today the for UK CMOS agreed that we
should you raise the risks to the UK or
for nations to hide now in terms of what
can people do to make sure that we have
the the smallest impact
this epidemic that is possible and we
need to do this do the right things at
the right time and just to add one point
to the reasons that as a Patrick is just
given if people go too early they become
very fatigued this is going to be a long
haul it is very important we do not
start things in advance of need there
are several things we will need to do in
due course which it is not appropriate
to do at this stage I'll come on to one
of them at the end now the things we can
do now we can't emphasize too much the
point about washing hands that is
actually an incredibly powerful public
health intervention but the new things
from today are to ask anybody who has a
cough that is continuous and new or a
temperature for those who choose to
measure their temperature 37 8 some
people will do it just based on the fact
that they have a temperature in terms of
feeling we wish those people to stay at
home for seven days now the reason for
this and I wanted to be clear about this
because we are asking people to do
something which will interfere with
their lives and interfere with their
work and their social life in quite a
significant way so it's important people
understand why this is going to help the
national effort to combat this farce the
first thing is it helps to protect older
and more vulnerable people who they
might come directly or indirectly into
contact with the second thing is as
patrick has pointed out this helps to
reduce the peak of the epidemic so that
it is a lower peak making it easier for
the NHS and health services in all four
nations to cope as this goes through the
third thing is that it can lead to
increased delay pushing it further into
the area where the NHS is under less
pressure and giving us more time to get
our countermeasures as optimal as
possible I finally just wanted to make a
point about why it's seven day
the virus seems to have this maximum
transmission around the time of the
first symptoms and for two or three days
afterwards and then rapidly declines so
that by four days the great set of by
seven days the great majority of people
are not infectious and it is fine for
them to go back into society now you may
ask why are we asking people with minor
symptoms to do this and the answer is
the evidence would appear to be that
some people with really quite mild
symptoms can spread this virus to a lot
of people so people with minor symptoms
should stay at home for seven days now
there is an additional point I want to
re-emphasize from the prime minister
which is just as people would not
normally if they had a - sprain or other
minor problem call for an ambulance
it is important that people with very
minor symptoms do not call one one one
however if their symptoms start to
deteriorate and they're getting to the
point where they normally would have
sought medical care at that point we
would want them to call one one one or
wave as they normally would have done so
we're not expecting people to stay at
home as they gradually deteriorate if
there's a certain point people are
really worried at that point they should
call service but doing it routinely with
minor symptoms is not a useful thing to
do for them and if we put a big burden
on the service making it harder for
others to get through with what may be
life life-threatening conditions there
are a few other changes that didn't go
alongside this the first of which is it
is no longer needed for us to identify
every case and we will move from having
testing may need owning homes and
outpatients and walk walking centers to
a situation where people who are self
who are remaining at home do not need
testing and we will pivot all of the
testing capacity to identify the
in hospitals who have got symptoms so we
can pick them up early make sure we
treat them well and ensure that they
don't pass on the virus to other people
in hospitals so that we're changing the
hospital and other testing systems and
finally we will no longer have any
geographical limits to who gets tested
the testing we based on symptoms and
severity so it's no longer relevant
where someone has come from this is
going to be people irrespective of their
travel history I want to just make two
points in addition to that the first one
is the next stage along we are going to
want to do a package of things which are
about putting social distancing around
the people who are vulnerable who are
older people and those with severe
health conditions but we do not think it
is appropriate to make a national
recommendation for that at the moment
because this is too early in the course
of the epidemic that's a Patrick passed
on and if you think about what would
happen if you prematurely put elderly or
vulnerable people in a situation where
you're saying we really want to cut down
on your social interactions we really
want to cut back on every kind of thing
where you might come into contact with
others it has big practical implications
for them and it may lead to loneliness
and other issues which are clearly very
undesirable threat so whilst we will
need to move to that stage we do not
think this is the right moment along the
pandemic to do so at that point will
come finally are we in mitigation phase
the answer is this is the stage we need
to do the things we can to mitigate
which means to reduce the pressure on
the NHS and other health services and
that is basically made up of two parts
the first part is reducing the peak so
that the demand on the service is
reduced and that is what the
interventions were talking about today
with people staying at home or helped to
do and the second part is to increase
the
Basti and flexibility of the NHS so that
it is better able to compete to meet the
very considerable demands that are going
to be heading its way when we reach the
peak of this epidemic thanks Chris okay
well let's go to some questions from
Laura prime minister and this is as you
say the worst public health crisis for a
generation there may be as many as
10,000 cases already how sure are you
that the approach you're taking holding
back from some of the more drastic
measures is the right one you say you're
guided by the science but if it turns
out to be the wrong approach there
consequences would be extremely grave
well we're guided by the science and
everything that we do lore and just on
the the delay for instance the issue
about elderly people and the the
protection of elderly people asking ugly
people to stay at home that's one thing
that you've really got to time as Chris
and Patrick have been explaining so that
it coincides with the period in which
the epidemic is really at ease and it's
peak so you need to make sure that you
move that that that fury when we are
asking older people vulnerable people to
go through a pretty difficult period of
of isolation and we only make it weak
tyne it says to to coincide with the
moment when they are most exposure most
risk of exposure to the to the illness
that's that's one of the reasons why
we're not triggering that draconian
measure now if you see what I mean and
on the the issue for instance of mass
gathering sporting events and and so on
it is very important
we're guided by the by the science there
is there is very little epidemiological
or medical reason at the moment to
balance such events as I think Nicola
Sturgeon First Minister of Scotland has
has also made clear but in Scotland they
they do have particular issues with the
resilience of their public services and
we will want to be keeping that issue
under review here across the UK as well
because you know let's let's be clear
that may become a factor for all of us
and we may also be wishing to go forward
with stopping those kinds of events as
well so we're not saying no to that sort
of measure of course not we're keeping
it our parsley but it's very very
important that we get we get that in
order to maximise the benefits of our
interventions that we get that the
timing right one thing about which is an
important part of the science on this
you've actually the behavioral science
and what that shows is probably common
sense to everybody in this audience
which is that people start off with the
best of intentions but enthusiasm at a
certain point starts to flag if you
start too early and then people's
enthusiasm runs I have just about the
peak which is exactly the time that we
want people to be doing these
interventions that is actually not a
productive way to do it so we do need to
do it at the last point it is reasonable
so people when maintain their energy and
enthusiasm to get through what will be
quite difficult things to do it sounds
trivial to say stay at home if you have
minor symptoms I waiting city of doing
it
yeah and you arise this is going to be
difficult and the other things we're
asking are going to be difficult and
it's important we do not ask our fellow
citizens to do them for longer than make
sense from the epidemiology the delay is
to maximize the effect it's not simply
to delay it's exactly as
said to make sure we don't end up with
everything coming off just what you
don't want it to come off thanks of
Prime Minister
the US has stopped flights from Europe
Italy has closed down completely Ireland
today has closed its school but your
action plan basically means asking
people to stay at home if they feel ill
and avoid cruises can you understand why
people watching this might think you'll
do far too little to protect their
families and to the chief medical
officer by May
German Chancellor Angela Merkel told the
German people this week she thought
seven out of ten of them will catch
Korean virus do you think that sort of
level will apply in the UK and can you
level with us and based on your graphs
say how many people do you think will
actually die thank you I mean we have to
look at the epic acity of the the
measures that were bringing forward and
this immediately as I said to write
we're looking at the science and the
measures that I've discussed today with
you staying at home if you think you
have the symptoms your whole household
staying home looking after the elderly
making sure the elderly vulnerable stay
at home these are the three most
powerful defensive lines and I've asked
Patrick to say a bit about that the
percentages that these measures will be
able I think according to our scientific
advice to reduce the fatigue we think
it's very important to maintain public
trust and confidence in what we're doing
throughout this this challenging time
always to be guided by the best possible
scientific advice that you get about 20
to 25 percent reduction in peak we've
getting people to stay at home for seven
days if they've got mild symptoms you'd
get something like a 25% reduction if
you
to the whole household isolation and
those additives you'd expect to get up
towards 50 plus and then looking after
the elderly in terms of preventing them
from getting effective that's not so
much about stopping or reducing the
transmission in society that's about
then not getting it that has a bigger
effect from death where you'd expect
about 20 to 30% reduction in death rate
so those are the three most important
measures to take it doesn't mean other
things don't have additional effects as
well but those are the ones which have
the biggest effect and therefore they
need to be come to come in first you can
bring in other things later and it's
important I think not to go to things
that have relatively small effects but
sound very sensible because that puts
people off doing the things that really
matter and it's also important we keep
stressing to do this in a way that's
sustainable because we're not talking
about measures that you're going to do
for a week or two these are measures
which we have to have in place over the
whole course of the epidemic so can I
have an additional point on the
schooling which i think is something
which obviously families really care
about and then I'll answer directly your
question on the numbers while schooling
the additional points of in addition to
the modeling it's so one reason to close
schools is going to have a big impact on
the epidemics patrick is already covered
that a second reason is if children are
particularly affected by a virus or some
other infection that fortunately and
there are this is one silver lining if
you wish in this particular infection it
looks as if children are affected much
less than adults based on the early days
where we had at the moment our view is
not that they don't get infected we
think they probably do but they seem to
have a much milder disease in general so
the second possible reason to close
schools does not appear to be there and
of course closing schools has big
knock-on effects across all of society
so it has to be justified by very strong
reasons either protection of children or
for the impact on the epidemic
in the absence of those the evidence
we're doing this is quite weak in terms
of being level as you put it with
numbers I have been absolutely level on
every number in which I have confidence
actually our top number for our
reasonable worst-case scenario is higher
than the Chancellor's in fact our top
planning assumption would be up to 80%
of the population being infected but
that is an entirely speculative number
now we do know something about the
mortality rate I've discussed that
before I'm very happy to go through that
but the overall mortality rate is in our
view Patrick and I completely agree on
this one percent or less overall
although higher in older and vulnerable
groups and lower in other groups the bit
we actually do not know and I'm really
not in favor of putting what I consider
basically speculative numbers which are
kind of made-up just for convenience
into the public domain is what
percentage of people are actually
infected if you multiply by the one by
the other then you'll get a number but
we do not know and if you look around
the world nowhere so far is coming
anywhere near the 80% which is our top
reasonable worst-case scenario as soon
as we get a clear indication as to what
we think is a reasonably stable number
or that I'm very happy to then do what
is a pretty straightforward mathematical
calculation and say this is where we
think we will land what I'm trying to
avoid and Patrick is as well who's
trying to be really clear about what we
know really sure about where we've got
numbers that we think are reasonable
estimates or reasonable worst-case
estimates and not put into the public
domain numbers which in my you don't
actually are really basically
speculative this day on day that day to
see where we are ask you to just on a
couple of the points that bethe phrase I
know would be of concern to lots of you
the specific questions about in the
stopping plane flights and
and stopping a sporting event I think
people who want to know
why there is did not commend themselves
to the scientific advisory group
emergencies and you know what I think he
is there so quite early on we looked at
the question of stopping flights and the
assessment was if we stop flights
directly from China at the beginning
unless you've got something like a 95
percent effect in other words you could
stop all the routes from China to the UK
by 95 percent the effect on the delayed
epidemic was minimal it was a day or two
and more realistically we could get at
best probably 50% reduction so that this
really wasn't going to make a big
difference I think the evidence has
borne that out actually that you can't
in in the way the world works you cannot
stop that unless everybody decides to do
it all at once and it's certainly too
late now to be trying to do that the
sort of problem the second one was the
planes actually the other thing is of
course the the the screening measures on
air force as we know sort of sounded
sensible but we know that for example
the first case in the u.s. went through
the screening major and that was the
first person wasn't detected and then
popped up so these things sound great
but that don't always work the sporting
events of course there is a risk and I
explained this last time that as one
individual you have who's infected you
are releasing virus from your body as
you cough or sneeze or Tucker or put
fluids onto onto surfaces bong average
one person infects two or three others
you therefore have a very low
probability of infecting a large number
of people in a stadium or rather higher
probability of infecting people very
close to you and that means that most of
the transmission tends to take place
actually with friends and colleagues and
things in a closed environment not in
the big environments so it is true of
course that any cancellation of things
you can
some effect if you can get a
displacement activity where you end up
with everyone congregating somewhere
else you may actually have perversely an
increase this particularly in an
endorsed environment so it doesn't mean
you shouldn't at some point make the
decision for the resilience point that's
being discussed but this is not a major
way to tackle this epidemic the major
ways to tackle it are to try and reduce
and delay the transmission across
households and across people who've
become infected and that's why that's
the concentration of the first actions
and they're not trivial actions these
are quite difficult things for people to
actually comply with and to do from the
mirror a couple of questions for me
first one is about stature sick pain
prime-minister you made announcements or
tossed let me turn item into the budget
yesterday which cover a lot of people
but there's still some gig workers and
low paid workers that aren't going to be
covered by it and all therefore have to
bark on there on the benefit system and
to the benefit system can you keep the
door open to looking again at whether
some of those workers might be covered
by SSP rather than forcing them onto
Universal Credit which is quite
difficult system to get their heads
around and secondly quickly ask you
whether you have any concerns yourself
you're coming into a lot of contacts a
lot of people in small environments
rather than mass gatherings but the
yourself of any concerns or worries like
a lot of people do about getting
coronavirus and whether as Prime
Minister you've got measures in place
with your Theor first secretary state
Olivos Dominic Rob to step in should you
be incapacitated for any length of time
thank you
it's very important that we do
everything we can to protect people who
are not necessarily eligible for SSI
that reduces pain you saw what we did by
advancing statutory sick pay were there
instruments today that will help people
who were
not in not in work were self-employed on
benefits the crucial thing is that we
will do everything that is necessary to
make sure that when you ask people to do
something tough as chris has just been
saying something difficult like staying
at home and protecting other people that
you're not disadvantaged no one is
penalized for doing the right thing and
on that on the second thing when I
understand washing my hands and Mesa
Mesa Thank You Prime Minister Mesa
hopefully Daily Express lots of people
on this will be keen to do their bit and
help out whether it's helping our
overstretched NHS or public services or
helping protect the vulnerable are you
planning any form of register or
anything in advance so that people with
the right skills can can do the right
job at become for the country in his
hour of need
indeed Mesa we are and I know that Matt
Hancock has set up a system so that
people wanting and people principle
wanted to come back into the NHS people
who who have skills it could be a value
to the country now I will have a way of
doing that and contributing we certainly
encourage our people to think of doing
that in the weeks ahead Jason great
Daniel thank you for minister just to
follow up Moses point you ask the people
to mobilize to support each other
through this crisis I wonder what sorts
of things you had in mind and so Patrick
can I just pick you up on a point you
made you said we were roughly four weeks
behind Italy should people be looking at
what's going on in Italy and thinking
Christ that's what we're gonna be facing
in a month thanks Jason we'll look at
all what people should be doing I think
that's it's a very really very important
question because in asking people to
turn the state
and look after themselves Keely that's
putting a burden and a necessity upon
others potentially to to help them to
bring them food and support so perhaps
I'll ask Patrick and Kristen to
elaborate on this problem we will
certainly be hoping that people will
think of their of their neighbors think
water if they are aware that people are
staying at home to protect the community
in the spread of the virus let's see
what we can do to help them don't forget
that I think the correct advice is not
to go within 2 meters but it should be
possible to help people I think that's
why I think all the bad will science
says that the the biggest effect during
times like this is not outbreaks of
panic it's actually outbreaks in
mattresses young people wanting to help
each other and whether that sort of
delivering things the neighbors whether
it's making sure that people got their
medicines and that I think is the effect
that we expect particularly in the UK in
answer to the questions about Italy on
the curve with maybe four weeks or so
behind in terms of the scale of the
outbreak and we're behind where Germany
and France are as well in terms of the
scale of the outbreak and you'd expect
it to follow a similar trajectory in
terms of the numbers not in terms of the
response and that's why the measures we
putting into place come into place today
to see whether we can deflect that and
get that into a different trajectory but
that's that's the unmitigated curve
would follow exactly that curve in terms
of numbers but of course that's
different from saying in terms of the
actions that have been taken thanks very
much Laura thank you and you've made it
very clear and that sort of loveliness
to the elderly is at the moment don't
stay home because pensioners can't they
won't be able to stick it
so weeks and months on end it's
something you can only ask people for a
finite period is it possible to talk a
bit about what the working assumptions
are for when that period kicks in and
how long old people might be expected to
try to stay home as much as possible how
old put that straight to the side of
your Bible maybe yes so we think that
the pipng like 10 to 14 weeks away it
could be a bit longer and you would want
to try to make sure that the elderly are
protected during the peak area about 95
percent of people that would be
predicted to get the infection over an
nine-week-old 10-week period either side
of the peak and about 50 percent would
be infected about three or four weeks
either side of the peak on the current
evidence of how the epidemic looks it
may change we put the measures in place
so that means that even to cover the
peak you're talking about trying to make
sure that those sorts of measures are in
place for 1314 weeks or so thank you yes
thing on that which is obviously what
we're giving is national recommendations
individual people may have discussions
with their own GP or specialist if there
aren't specialist care that said that
this is something which is appropriate
for them even now but what we will be
doing is giving very clear and hopefully
relatively detailed guidance for people
when we get to the point we think across
the country as a whole this seems a
sensible thing to do thank you hello
Prime Minister listen over from Reuters
I was just wondering if I proposed this
question to all of you really I mean how
how confident are we of the data the
international data and how and how can
we really know whether we understand the
behavior of this illness when we not
necessarily have a chance to verify that
data and how does that affect how we
plan to deal with this crisis well my
question is that there are some
countries which are having some success
in the Britain in reducing the incidence
of the of the disease and whatever but
you know whether those statistics earth
entirely trustworthy or not the tendency
is is pretty clear I think the issue is
the one that was referred to earlier
which is that there may be measures that
we could take which were very dependent
in an immediate nature that really did
suppress drastically the contact between
deeds in this in this country but might
mean that the delay of the disease
simply came back surged back again in a
few months or in a few months time and
in a way that we weren't properly
protected for but I think there are
certain things we are very confident of
like the mortality rates which we know
initially we were uncertain of there are
also things we do not know and the most
important of those is how many people
get this infection without any symptoms
and the reason we don't know that is we
do not have a test that can tell us that
and depending on the answer to that
question this pandemic looks very
different so those are things we
definitely know things we don't know
tool like that and some things between
where we've got a reasonably good
estimate based on data from life
elsewhere but it's improving all the
time and one of the reasons why delay
helps us it's not the main reason is the
dark understanding of this virus
improves week on week and we're
narrowing down we have to to tell you
it's a pretty important development in
our
plan for beating back this this disease
I mean everybody's understood it already
is clear about what we're saying if you
have those there's two symptoms of you
have one rather of those two symptoms a
potential corona virus a high
temperature and a new and continuous
call then you should you should stay at
home and the reasons that we advise you
to do that is really that this will help
us to delay and platon the piece squash
that sombrero that you saw on the corner
on the map because that is the way to
minimize the suffering and minimize the
impact of this is he we will in the
course of the next few weeks be bringing
forward more measures to delay the
impact of the disease as we move through
the lead today anyway that's it but for
now don't forget wash your hands and we
will get through this thank you all very
much thank you
freaked out about markets these are
dramatic times these are three things
you should be keeping an eye on one the
corona virus infection numbers in the US
and Europe does the rate of increase in
numbers of new cases begin to slow after
a period of containment that would
follow the path we've seen in China and
South Korea and that would be very
encouraging - I asked my team this
question and the answer was credit
credit credit it's been the worst credit
market since the 2008 crisis keep an eye
on what companies can't roll their loans
keep an eye on what companies might go
bust and in response we need to work out
whether the fiscal packages that are
being delivered around the world will
get money to the small and medium size
enterprises that need it most
it's not just about providing liquidity
its ensuring that we get through this
crisis with as few companies going bust
3 the impact on the real economy in the
u.s. particularly next week which was
the exact period we are expected to see
the most intense impact on the global
supply chain disruption hit us factories
this is coinciding with the domestic
problem intensifying as well not many
people in the u.s. can work from home in
many industries what happens when large
sways the US economy shut down I'm mark
cut mark I run Bloomberg's markets live
analysis team
Italy is now almost in a full lockdown
all non-essential services will be
halted in the country for the next 15
days and now no more coffees at a bar
number pizzas normal lunch outside
everything is a shutdown every
activities related to food is shut down
the only one open our bakeries and the
groceries so Italian can still go and
buy their favorite fruits and vegetables
can still go to supermarket actually
contact old Italians don't rush to buy
foods and goods everything will be
available don't be in a hurry but we
already saw several queues in front of
the main supermarkets on Villain why
because people should stay at least one
meter away away one from each other so
this is creating long akyuu in front of